so this is his garage bedroom her bed
and then this see here this is his
address though hasn't he made so the
last time I saw them was at the airport
when they caught the plane to go to Iran
had lunch there Gabriela after a couple
of having a lunch decides that then she
was needed to go and explore so we had a
good 20 minutes I remember clearly of
her running up and down the corridors
and then you know she went and and got
the plane with her mom and obviously
Natalie's head was just full of gosh
houses flight gonna be and how will we
cope with this wait quite precocious yes
she was then the realization that
actually she was being held in solitary
confinement and being interrogated in
this sort of brutal way it's not that I
it was surreal it was it was it was sort
of much deeper I mean just really sort
of shocking and and you know when you
you suddenly aren't able to sleep you
aren't able to concentrate on anything
you aren't able to do it it's not even
as if I had clear thoughts about what
was going on but I'd had clear sort of
shaking feelings she was taken to a
place called Carmen which is down on the
south Ron and kept there for 45 days in
solitary confinement she always says
that was the worst period of all of her
experience she was kept in a room about
the size of a double bed pretty dirty no
natural light the light would be on all
the time and then every soft when she'd
be taken out for interrogation not
allowed to ever speak to anyone about
that interrogation afterwards vaguely
being promised she was going to be
released if she cooperated then I was
taken away so all sorts of sort of dis
annotation and light when she came out
of solitary she couldn't walk took her
more than ten days to be able to have
this journey begun to walk certainly
certainly her mood and her ability to
control her mood is very very unstable
so you know on the phone
we're very angry sometimes she can
sometimes be very happy and sometimes
just really sad and needing so much
pressure on so it'll be okay I play the
bass strain cliffs
yes seeing Gabriella what she lives to
in the days between single by and large
is we are making some clothes for her or
planning what we're gonna do together
fundamentally think that nastiness story
is is it profound to justice and and
should be said I fundamentally think
that the government can sold it and the
Iranian government could solve it and
it's not my business how but it is my
business to give them an incentive to do
it and that's that's what I tried to do
there's always been a tension between me
and the government so the government has
always wanted to sort of keep has needs
case a low-profile and quiet and I've
always wanted to happen as needs cases
in the headlights and the headliners the
last few weeks have been a complete
roller coaster we've had all sorts of
bad things happen some good things
happen and you know I sit here now
thinking gosh what to make sense of it I
think my hopes are that the project
really does go to Iran as soon as
possible he didn't give a date on the
meeting but but I think was within the
next few weeks and and obviously my
hopes are to go with him and to be
alongside him on that plane but also
then to be able to see Nazneen and
Gabriella and just to spend some time
together she likes to look at the photos
that were they over here I will sweet
miss Gabriella on skype and typically
sort of tea time which is kind of nearer
to her bedtime so she's winding down as
well and obviously as time has gone on
the beginning she had a much closer
memory of being with me now it's a much
more distant memory of Beeman's so now
I'm kind of phone dad rather than the
real dad one of my fondest memories is I
was putting on the stereo the Michael
Jackson and her dancing around she used
to start dancing and then get another
dolly dolly we have to start dancing
another Dalia s we end up with all these
dollies dancing wonderful acts she was
busy organizing her own
stir to hold all our dollars I think my
job is not to believe any promises not
to believe any sort of reassurances I
can't see so when the government says
that we're raising Couture whatever no I
see what I can see and I can see she's
not here yet so I'm gonna keep going